[music]
lemoine john
language through place where there's a drill
commanders clown my name is weak i'm a clown
i live everywhere as a spirit
with our life Mikhalych apple and
his weak personality and expect fan art is a
course on an you stand and then I
got tired of working dozens I decided to
found a world academy of fools
who now has a residence in this
dog
we have a lot of beautiful projects and today
we decided that  the very simple topic of a picnic
thought jan and slavy checking space on
chemistry back
cutter army fools and van gogh shops
and 2 sauce he them cheap wonderland
first i love life i love people
especially creative people years among them
very comfortable harmoniously i am in love with
creativity and than  the more around me
the more of me I can create too and it doesn't
matter what you do boots or your
lunch or eat clothes or would you burn the
main just when t  you create also
creates that the earlier in this world there
was no
realization your your teeth
[music]